dude just trying to like find a model
last night i was like starting to get a
little ill i'm just looking at the
spider
[Music]
i know you're messing with me but like
a primal part of me just panicked
[Music]
oh dude hey check this out
check out that wallpaper i just threw
this on the corridor subreddit so if you
want this as a wallpaper go check that
out today marks the first because
we are beginning visual effects on our
first quarter video of the year
and i'm actually really excited it's
been like a month and a half since i got
really dive into some visual effects so
let's get into it
they spent the last couple days editing
this sequence that they shot over the
weekend it actually turned out pretty
funny at this point you probably know
the concept
uh he shoots webs out of his butt
there are a number of effects here i
think there's at least a dozen so not
too many but a couple of them are gonna
be a little challenging we're gonna have
to do some rope simulations there's
several shots where i gotta like add
like this mosaic
censored effect over his butt
here's the thing though i do not like
spiders and that is an understatement i
was i've resisted my whole life from
doing any sort of spider effects
because they make me sick this is like
the classic spider-man shot where the
the spider dangles down from the lens
the lens is pointed down and i realized
that uh
wasn't as bad as last night
is that brett
i'm light-headed now
viewers might not believe me i'm allowed
to laugh with you dubai
i have to actually find a high quality
spider model which i want to absolutely
not do
and then also animate the legs another
thing that i have dreaded my entire life
and then render it out as photo real as
i can i'm just going to type spider i'm
i'm already is that even a 3d model that
looks real man
i mean that is a pretty nicely detailed
video you know how like you're supposed
to face your fears by look at the
picture
can we like just pause that for a moment
please
pretty gnarly
man now i'm getting flashbacks to like
times in my life there's a time when i
was doing construction on a house and i
picked up a rubber boot and a black
widow crawled right out of it and over
my hand and i dropped it and went home
here is a hundred dollar black widow
it's
that's really high detail
pretty dang high detail there's even
hair on it yeah
this one's not bothering me as much
we'll have a black widow effect
that we can
red i'm sorry
i'm sorry ren
so funny so funny everyone
blanks here check this out it's the
easiest simulation you can do because i
have 3ds max open right now and if i
just make a box then i make a plane just
make a big play a plane is just like a
flat
box hit the t-shirt button
move it up and over then i hit the play
button
basically you do a cloth sim and then
you render a web texture on top of that
using the web as also an opacity map so
that is see-through in the places that
the spider web is black but anywhere the
spider web is white it's opaque aka the
web even though it's a cloth that's
being simulated over something you're
only seeing the web pattern and you're
seeing through everything that is not
the web so it looks like there's just a
spider web draped over jake whereas in
reality
it's a blanket what i did was i
simulated the blanket i had gravity
going this way the blankets fall wrap
around him then i turn off gravity i
turn up the wind turbulence a little bit
pin the blankets to the wall and plate
various places around him which gets
like the little jiggly effect going the
original footage he has like silly
string all over them and that kind of
just helps add some parts to it so you
can see the spiderweb on off on off
so yeah that is a jake on the wall i'm
still going to put things like blurring
on it to match it to the shot and the
blurring just kind of crushes the detail
the extra high detail you get from the
render basically the more crisp your 3d
render looks the less realistic it looks
see that's that's the thing i'm like
hyper
i'm like hyper sensitive to this stuff
right now just because i'm on edge
so a reason why i have this big fear is
because when i was a kid i lived in
louisiana and they have what are called
banana spiders i don't know what their
actual name is but they're literally
this big they have these abdomens that
are like freaking bananas they're huge
and they like to string webs between
like
towns so you're walking along and all of
a sudden you have this massive spider
this big just on your face wanting to
rip my eyes out let's google it let's
fulfill the story
oh look at the hand
yeah
yeah oh there's a spider in a banana bag
i have to get some air
let's set his background as a spider
i apologize for this intentional
infliction of emotional distress
but it's totally worth it
we're done with this segment i'm gonna
move on to something non-spider-like for
a bit it's easy for me when there's not
an actual one there
or an image of one
i'm going to focus on just making all
the project files and starting with like
making webs and stuff i'm looking
forward to doing a rope simulation i
just want to put off that spider stuff
man clint's so freaking funny
yeah like i was saying i'm actually
really excited to start these effects
where did you uh get that desktop by the
way
[Applause]
can you change that i don't want it
i don't want to change it
so money
no where'd you save the original render
i can't find it thanks a lot
[Music]
[Music]
having to
animate the legs the shot is literally
the spider falling so what do spiders do
when their legs fall they kind of just
like dangle there and spread out and
stuff so it's like i had to actually
animate those legs fortunately the model
came with some like really good rigged
controls so i was able to really easily
move the legs but i still had to do it
[Music]
hey carmichael i have finished all of
the effects except for this one and the
money grab shot which is just like a
clock sim rope sort of thing
it's it's not real
i've learned that you guys are all jerks
i've learned that
gabe just laughs
i never did anything
here's the thing i'm not as afraid of uh
these little guys as i used to be
and by these little guys i mean
specifically this black widow model
if there's an actual black wood on my
desk that would be an entirely different
story
a freaking crazy spider bit me and i got
all his powers i just found out i got
another ticket for tonight's show
so what happened after that